microsoft trains a universal image
language representation model facebook
gets all touchy touchy and the russkies
release their own dali model welcome to
ml news
hello there this video is sponsored by
weights and biases tables yes the video
is sponsored by a feature that's a new
thing now you haven't seen that before
so weights by these tables is an
interactive way to not only explore your
experiments like you would usually do
with weights and biases but to explore
your data as well and the combinations
of your data your models your
predictions your experiments anything
you want essentially can go into a table
you can see they can include pictures
even little sound files that can include
videos they can include image samples
and overlay the model's predictions as a
mask as you can see here and you can
compare different models to each other
in a single table this is extremely
powerful and if the user interface is
not enough they have a special syntax
with which you can do pretty much
anything you want really cool for
visualizing predictions such as this one
look here is the picture and then the
overlays of the masks of the model now
it's probably my browser that doesn't
load that fast enough but the effect is
a cool one let's see that again
oh yeah
so it's also really powerful if you want
to compute some metrics on the fly like
counting false positives counting false
negatives area under curve f1 score
anything like this very cool so they
have this example of a data set of
reddit comments i know red is the most
wholesome place on the planet and this
data set is annotated with all kinds of
emotions whether or not they appear in
the comment by human raters so you can
load this data set directly into a
weights and biases table and then do all
kinds of analysis with it honestly it
might just be cool to just load the data
set in without even having to do any
sort of experiments on it because this
is a great viewer for example i can
filter all the rows which contain both
joy
equals one
and sadness equals one
how's that so apply the filter and i can
immediately see all the comments that
match both joy and sadness okay what are
these let's see
that made me cry tears of sadness and
joy at the same time excellent that's
what we're looking for another really
cool feature is the ability to group by
certain columns so here i group by
subreddit and then we can analyze all
kinds of stuff across these different
groups for example let me add a column
here that tracks ratio of sadness inside
of each subreddit sadness.sum divided by
row.count should give us that result and
we have a result and now we can sort by
this and look at that the soccer is in
third place who would have guessed
though it only has 12 samples so maybe
we would want some more complicated
metric luckily with weights and biases
you can put all kinds of expressions in
the cell expression tables and if that
is not enough for you they have a
special syntax with which you can create
entire panels and visualizations give
weights and biases as a whole a try it's
cool system and thanks for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
hey how's everyone doing on this
wonderful monday let's dive into our
first story on their research blog
microsoft says they have trained a
universal image language representation
model called turing bletchley now
touring is the effort by microsoft to go
into large-scale models large-scale
language models for example and
bletchley is a reference i believe to
bletchley park where alan turing cracked
the enigma not entirely sure my concept
of these things is based off of
hollywood movies in any case this is a
model much like clip that combines text
and image modalities and not only that
but it also combines text from different
languages so this is really a model that
can understand the relationship between
images and text in various languages all
in the same embedding space they
achieved this by crawling the internet
for images that come alongside text in
various languages and then they have
basically two different objectives one
objective is to make the image
representation close to the
representations of the various texts
that go with the image and the other
loss is to have the representations of
two pieces of text that go with the same
image also be close together and that
means they achieve a representation
space where concepts no matter whether
they're expressed in images or in any
language cluster together if they mean
the same thing so they demonstrate this
on various different examples right here
for example the model understands a
coca-cola ad irrespective of the
languages it can do a little bit of ocr
and recognize words and it's not only
for natural images but as you can see
right here it also understands things
like maps and the multi-modality means
that you can even mix languages and
scripts as you put things into the model
and the model will still understand it
for example on the left here it says
posing for a photo at the great wall of
china but the great wall of china is
spelled in chinese characters and as you
can see the nearest neighbors in the
embedding space are still models where
people pose for a photo at great wall of
china
cat programming
this cat isn't programming how do you
know these cats are programming this is
clearly a gamer cat they even have a
little demo right here now here is where
you see the smart pr people and lawyers
come in all of the queries that you're
able to do there are a lot of them but
they are all pre-programmed so even
though you can type here you can only
select one of the things that are
already in here for example space needle
at night crazy pants no i think this
isn't so much because they want to
present you cherry-picked examples it's
probably much more so people can't
retrieve things like not safe for work
images and even images that might have
some copyright associated with it that
ended up in this data set but there is
an interface for english queries
universal queries and even image queries
so you can try out what the model thinks
which are images which are sort of close
in the space of meaning now here's a
fatal flaw if i'm not mistaken this here
is actually song gohan and not song goku
as all the others so that changes
everything terrible model
meta ai facebook ai meta underscore
facebook ai says today as part of a
larger tactile sensing ecosystem we're
announcing two major advances digit a
commercially available touch sensing
hardware produced in partnership with
gel site and reskin a replaceable
low-cost tactile skin so facebook is
going into the hardware of touch sensors
and general tactile data this isn't just
hardware this is sort of a big
conglomeration of new advances in
hardware coupled with machine learning
advances so the first one is reskin a
versatile replaceable low-cost skin for
ai research on tactile perception so
this is really a piece of skin a piece
of soft material that can sense when it
touches something so you can see right
here this patch of skin that the person
attached here to the robot hand allows
the robot to get tactile feedback as it
grabs things which is pretty cool
because grabbing something like a
blueberry is very hard when you don't
want to squish it and as you saw maybe
up here one robot simply you know dealt
like no so there are several advances
right here and they're not all hardware
advances notably usually you'd have to
recalibrate every single individual one
of these skin sensors because this being
soft material you can't really
manufacture it in such a consistent way
that all the sensors achieve the same
accuracy so you can't just calibrate
once you have to recalibrate every
individual thing and the recalibration
in this case as far as i can read is
done using a self-supervised technique
rather than supervised calibration which
makes things a whole lot easier so there
are various applications for this you
can see that not only do you get tactile
feedback of whether you're touching
something you actually do also see where
you touch something so there are like
enormous amounts of applications for
this technology this goes along with
another technology called digits which
is also a touch sensor but it is a
little bit different namely these are
the small sensors that you can see right
here so this isn't necessarily
deformable skin but this is a very high
precision touch sensor like you might
have it in a fingertip i guess that's
why it's called digit also they say that
this is quite low cost and they have
open sourced the design now as you can
see here the resolution on sensing on
these sensors is quite high you can see
it's able to sense very very very
detailed things on the things that it
grabs this goes along with a new pytorch
library that they've built called pi
touch that is able to take in this data
and transform it in various ways and
also they are open sourcing tacto which
is a simulator for these types of data
so all in all meta facebook is really
making an advance into this tactile
ecosystem reskin deformable skin digit
the super high precision touch sensor
tacto the simulator and pi touch the
library and they say soon they'll be out
with a bunch of data sets and benchmarks
for people very cool i'm quite excited
to see the technologies that are going
to be possible with the sensors and
processing tools
anime gan is all the rage right now all
timelines of all my social networks are
filled with people tunifying themselves
and and putting their faces and pictures
into anime again and it does look quite
cool so this is a series of advancements
right here starting from classic anime
gan improving this to animegan v2 which
makes various improvements over the
classic animegan by the way this is a
mixture of a style transfer and a
generative adversarial network the code
to anime gan was released in tensorflow
but has been ported to pytorch and that
again has been released as a space on
hugging face that you can just try out
so here is a picture of me it looks kind
of weird here's a picture of the channel
logo that just looks disturbing here's a
picture of some industry that looks
actually pretty cool as the output and
here's a picture of captain picard and
we'll see what happens
yeah that looks pretty sweet so what i
want to highlight besides the fact that
this is a cool model it's just the chain
of individuals or individual groups that
just loosely work together to achieve
something like this from the original
research to its improvements its release
as code the transformation into various
frameworks and then in the end the
deployment as a really user-friendly
interface that you can use for free this
whole ecosystem is quite quite cool and
pretty happy it exists so i'll link
everything you can try it out
researchers from mit release a paper
called a system for general in-hand
object reorientation and this is pretty
cool because it teaches robot hands here
in simulation to reorient any sort of
object and it can reorient objects that
are as you can see very very tricky from
given their form and it can even do that
in a zero shot fashion so the trick here
is that this is a student teacher model
so the final model the student only has
access to sort of the sensors in the
hands like how the joints are oriented
right now and to the visual input of a
camera however it turns out that is
quite tricky to learn from you are given
the object and you're given a target
pose and you need to rotate it somehow
to the target pose now the task would be
a lot easier if you had access to what
they call privileged data such as the
velocity of the fingertips and so on and
that you do have access if you're in a
simulator so the trick here is that they
first train a model that gets access to
all that privileged information learns
what to do using that information and
then teaches the student model what to
do so the student model doesn't have to
learn through reinforcement learning but
it can instead learn from a very very
good teacher exactly what to do in a
supervised way and with this method they
achieve very strong even zero shot
performance on new object whether the
hand is upright like this or turned
around like this it can even use the
table as as help pretty cool and pretty
simple
the washington post writes five points
for anger one for a like how facebook's
formula fostered rage and misinformation
and by now you should be aware that when
you read an article like this that the
journalist here wants to tell some sort
of a story so what you usually have to
do is you have to go to the very very
bottom and read like the last three
paragraphs such that you actually get
what's going on so the whole article is
about how facebook over the years has
changed its algorithm to rank different
posts on your page there seems to be a
sort of a point system for example when
someone likes your post that post gets
one point if someone comments on your
post that post gets whatever 10 points
or something like this and these points
are then used to score your post among
all other posts in your friends and
followers uh news feeds now the article
here is quite long and details how
facebook evolved this algorithm as well
over the years especially after the
introduction of additional things so it
used to be just like for a post and
apparently now you can also do love haha
wow sad and angry i've actually stopped
using facebook except for posting videos
even before this was the case but you
now have various emojis in order to
react to content so the article tries to
tell the story specifically about the
angry emoji people reacting to that and
then the algorithm boosting this content
and this sort of ties to this notion
that what facebook's trying to do is to
make people as angry as possible such
that it maximizes their engagement and
so on and you know while there is truth
to the fact that when something makes
you angry it makes you more engaged the
article's tone and the actual things
that happen don't really match up again
this seems to be a recurrent theme in
these articles so when you read the
article neutrally you can see that the
problem is actually not that easy for
example you can see that the title says
five points for anger one for a like and
you would somehow guess that facebook
intentionally uprated the anger emoji
which is not the case they simply
operated all of the emojis except the
like emoji and the reasoning behind it
was that in order to use the other
emojis you actually have to do two
clicks and in order to use the like you
only get to do one click therefore a
user doing two clicks is more effort
means they engaged more means this
should be operated in comparison to when
a post only receives a like in addition
to that facebook was also trying to push
these new features of these new emojis
and that's what platforms often do look
at youtube shorts or youtube polls or
things like this is that they massively
upway the new features just to get
people to use them and then later
they'll downway them again so it was
technically true at that particular
point in time an angry emoji was five
times more worth to the algorithm than a
like but do you think that framing it as
the article does here especially as the
title of the article is a fair
characterization of what happened well i
don't think so and the rest of the
article essentially goes on in this tone
where you have difficult problems and
you're trying to come up with some
sensible solution that weighs a lot of
interest against each other one being
profit but not the only one and then
that solution not being perfect and
having to be refined that is not the
same thing as mark zuckerberg sitting
there going like
everyone angry
and the kind of sleazy journalism of the
washington post right here is just not
helping if you want give the article a
read see if you can untie the
journalists framing right here from the
actual real problems that arise when you
program such a recommendation system
algorithm
demis hazovis tweets thrilled to
announce the launch of a new alphabet
company isomorphic labs our mission is
to reimagine the drug discovery process
from first principles with an ai first
approach to accelerate biomedical
breakthroughs and find cures for
diseases isomorphic labs appears to be a
new company under the umbrella of
alphabet therefore sort of a sister
company to google and deep mind and its
goal is to accelerate things like drug
discovery and various other things in
biology demis himself will be the ceo of
isomorphic labs but also remain the ceo
of deepmind now with deepmind going into
things like alpha fold making quite a
few advances applying ai to real world
things it probably makes sense to spin
this off into a single direction
business effort right here as isomorphic
labs while probably he wants to keep
deep mind more on the path of pushing ai
research in general and not that deep
mind suddenly becomes product
implementers for pharma companies or
something like this on the other hand
maybe it's just some scheme to save
taxes you never know
sherbank ai releases rudali which is a
russian version of the dali model the
original technical report is available
in russian but google translate is
fairly good nowadays they detail how
they went about building the model and
what they're releasing so they have two
different versions of it one with 1.3
billion parameters and one with 12. the
1.3 billion parameter model is actually
available this goes along with various
helper models such as their own version
of clip and a super resolution model to
do large images now i've heard somewhere
that they also want to open source the
really large model but i'm not exactly
sure that is super trustworthy so as i
said both the code and the models they
are released on on github you can go and
look at it and the outputs of this model
are pretty cool people are still
figuring out exactly how to prompt them
i think prompting has come a long way
given the whole clip and vqgan combos
and we'll probably have to learn how to
do the same thing with these dali based
models so they have a bunch of examples
right here and they all look very cool
there's also a space on hogging face
where you can simply type in something
now this uses a translation engine to
translate from english to russian
because you can only input things in
russian into the model so if things go
wrong you never really know is it
because of the translation is it because
of the prompt not being appropriate
enough or did the model fail so here i
input a purple tree on top of a mountain
it's not exactly what i wanted but
people have gotten quite cool results
with it there are also various notebooks
right here that you can try out and as i
said there is a technical report and the
project website if you're interested in
how all of it was built is quite
detailed and it recounts the engineering
challenges that the researchers had when
implementing this it's pretty cool to
see that after openai has already gotten
a few challengers in the large language
model space now more and more
challengers also appear in this dali in
this image generation from text space
the business model of not releasing your
models doesn't seem to hold up for too
long i guess if you wanted to do that
you also shouldn't publish about them
but as soon as you publish other people
are bound to reproduce your efforts
which is pretty cool for the rest of us
excellent
this tweet here has gotten a lot of
attention image scaling attacks in the
wild so this is a adversarial attack not
on deep learning systems but on
re-scaling procedures usually this
happens when you get an image you want
to input into a neural network the
neural networks usually have very
defined sizes of images that they take
in so you first resize the image now if
you craft an image very smartly you can
craft it such that the resized version
looks nothing like the original version
so you exploit how the resizing
algorithm resizes images in order to
achieve this goal it's pretty
unbelievable but if you do resize the
image on the left right here you
downscale it to the size on the right
then if you input it into the tensorflow
resizing algorithm this dog picture will
turn out again there's nothing else you
take the image on the left you put it
through the downscaling algorithm just
downscaling and the picture on the right
is the output that's because the picture
on the right is sort of like hidden in
the picture on the left in an exact way
such that once you down sample all the
original picture essentially cancels out
and this new picture appears now the
picture itself is actually from quite
old work or by old i mean like one year
which is ancient in deep learning world
but these image rescaling attacks have
been a thing for a while now so for
example here is a paper about
backdooring and poisoning neural
networks with image scaling attacks
there is an interesting take here from
richard chung which says that this is
essentially not a property of rescaling
itself but of faulty implementations of
rescaling in various libraries and there
have actually been papers written about
this problem namely that if you want to
calculate things like fid which is often
used in gan as a quality metric then it
actually matters how you rescale images
and if your rescaling algorithm doesn't
do proper anti-aliasing then the
rescaled images will have way too much
contributions from certain pixels and
way too little contributions from other
pixels so here for example if you ask
these libraries to re-scale the circle
on the left which is
by 128x128 to 16x16 only the pill python
image library does a good job at it
whereas all the other libraries you can
see right here they have various under
or over contributions of different
places in the image and this is exactly
the weak spots that these image
rescaling attacks use in order to attack
these images so the solution here would
be that the frameworks implement proper
rescaling of images which might cost a
little bit of speed so it's not
guaranteed that these will make it to
the final product
microsoft azure announces the open ai
service which essentially isn't an api
that you can query gpt3 with here they
have an example where gpt3 automatically
sort of summarizes sporting events from
live feeds and here is a neat corporate
little video about boxes and things that
connect things wow but essentially
you're able to call gpd3 in an azure
ecosystem right now so if you're an
azure customer you don't have to go
through open ai's api you can go
directly to azure this is invitation
only right now but i think it'll be
changed in the future and you can simply
have this as a service on azure
okay here's something cool neural mmo
i've actually reported about this before
but this has now been published at
nurips21
and there are continuous updates to the
framework the last commit is 13 days ago
so this is very much a project that is
alive this is a framework for running
reinforcement learning agents in big
worlds with other reinforcement learning
agents and that have to live for quite a
while so think of world of warcraft but
for rl agents now the worlds are still
quite simple because rl is a data and
compute intensive task so you don't want
to make things too complicated but this
is by far one of the most complicated
environments that i've seen so far
especially the introduction of other
agents into the world so you can have
different sort of species of agents and
and they'll find different niches in
order to survive and things like this
they do a pretty good job of giving you
various tools to analyze the results of
your runs so this could be used both for
researching reinforcement learning
agents but also researching various sort
of population dynamics if you're
interested in anything like this i think
they do hold competitions if i'm not
mistaken see there is even combat in the
game so if you're into challenges in
reinforcement learning that go beyond
just single player atari games or
something like this neural mmo might be
very cool to look into
another game that is not meant to be
played by machines but by humans is
archive doom so simon nick klaus made
this little piece of web-based doom
right here and the trick is wait let me
zoom out a little bit that it's doom but
the opponents are sometimes papers you
see not only are they papers but they
are as far as i have read recent papers
from archive
and once you shoot them they get
rejected see so this
is
wait let me show show your face paper
show your face ah yes i guess this is uh
so we can scroll down here to see this
is attack agnostic detection of
adversarial year rejected so there are
these these other opponents as well and
ah come on
you can actually die reject you can
switch your weapon as well so there's
this machine gun right here
and there's even this blaster
i've never i've never played doom i'm
sorry if this is standard i don't know
ah
go away
reject yeah if you want to have a bit of
fun give archive doom a try it's pretty
funny
next up at the intersection of what
machines and humans play is the arc game
this is by alexey borski and it takes
the arc dataset and makes it into a
little web-based game that you as a
human can play so we're gonna try just
one of these challenged things if you
don't know what the arc challenge is
i've made extensive videos about the
measure of intelligence so you
essentially get three different examples
right here so the top left is an example
the top right is an example the bottom
middle here is an example you're
supposed to just figure out the pattern
and then complete the pattern at the
bottom so here the pattern is that i
guess every one of these bows here spits
out a yellow thing so from no yellow
thing to yellow thing here as well here
as well so i'm gonna take the yellow
thing i'm gonna copy this over if you
click this right and then here we can
just we can color in actually whatever
we want but obviously this is
yeah
yeah we got it we are touring complete
stay another one okay so actually let's
do a hard one medium hard tedious no i
don't want tedious that's just too hard
okay one of the hard ones all right so
look at that so there is this and then
there's this
this so the blue thing seems to be
constant right we get four examples
right here okay um all right
okay
and then here ah okay so what's the the
catch right here i guess it's whatever
piece can fill from the bottom the holes
in the blue thing such that
it's like filled but it doesn't matter
if it reaches over right the only it
only matters whether you can actually
fill in the hole up until the blue
continuous line you can see why machines
would struggle like this so let's
actually check of whether i'm correct
and then you need to color them red like
once you figured out the rule you still
need to actually actively color them in
red so let's do this okay this one here
fills that first thing this one actually
doesn't fill it this one fills nothing
this one fills it let's
see see this is i'm terrible what is it
why not why not yeah yeah this goes here
this goes here yeah both of these could
go there yup oh come on this clearly
goes here this goes
ah
the bottom thing could technically go
here on the right
jeez
i failed the touring test yeah i mean uh
give it a try definitely
just this is very cute so this is a
twitter bot that takes memes and puts
them through res next classifier this is
classified as a skunk which is super
interesting right so i'm gonna guess
that is uh imagenet classes which
expects there to be a single thing per
image but still
skunk
[Music]
zillow has to lay off 25 of its
workforce and they stopped their house
flipping service so zillow is this real
estate company they used ai to assess
the prices of houses and then they went
in and bought these houses at what they
thought were low prices with the goal to
sell them at high prices but this didn't
work out these stories are from cbs news
and also business insider writes that
very often zillow has their homes at a
loss so they bought them for more than
they want to sell them at this is i
guess first and foremost a lesson in
what a.i can and can't do so it's very
hard sometimes for an ai to just look at
data that's available online and make a
judgment about a real life thing such as
a house two houses might be very
different even though their metadata
looks exactly the same and a local
realtor would know whereas this sort of
worldwide algorithm maybe doesn't as
much however it is special that there
are other companies doing pretty much
the same thing which are flourishing so
it might simply be a failure of zillow
itself and it might be not a lesson in
what ai can't do but in you can't just
throw ai at a problem and expect it to
perform well you have to actually go out
and look for good data you have to
program your algorithms correctly you
have to validate them and so on and all
of this appears to not really have
happened too well with zillow's
algorithm here so let this be a warning
if you're an ml engineer do a good job
don't make your company bankrupt
okay welcome to this week's helpful
things the first helpful thing is
pytorch lightning release 1.5
this is a major release of pi torch
lightning which if you don't know is a
framework around pytorch to make
training saving loading etc of models
much easier so the new things in pi
torch lightning are fault tolerant
training pytorch lightning can now
recognize when a training run abrupts
unexpectedly or when one of the machines
in a distributed run aborts and it can
restart training from where it left off
this allows you to use things like
preemptable machines without having to
worry about you yourself always making
sure that the machine isn't shut down or
taken away from you etc also very cool
lightning light is for when you have a
pure high torch model so not a pie torch
lightning model you can still use some
of the features of pi torch light by
simply wrapping the model in this
lightning light module and you do get
almost all of the basic benefits of pi
torch lightning such as multi-device
training multi-node training automatic
dispatching to accelerators and so on so
there are various other improvements
right here which i'm not going to
mention you can check them out for
yourself but i do like pi torch
lightning as a framework and it's cool
to see that it's still being improved
there's a new data set of league of
legends game playing data this is
essentially a recording of agents in the
game human agents and you are supposed
to learn from them so this is available
for you the data set contained 72 games
initially but now has been expanded to
contain 987
games they're all filtered to relatively
short games such that the individual
episodes aren't too long but this is
supposed to be a base data set for doing
offline reinforcement learning or
imitation learning from teacher
demonstrations if you're into lol and
would like to train agents for it maybe
this is a cool resource for you iris is
an open source alternative to google
photos this is a submission to the
pytorch annual hackathon 21 and it seeks
to provide the functionalities of google
photos especially that now google photos
does actually count your photos towards
your quota this is a welcome addition to
the ecosystem even though i don't think
that people are gonna self-host their
photos thing in the future but maybe
this will spur some kind of competition
so this is a framework that essentially
ingests your photos index system does
vector descriptions of your images but
also face detection and so on and after
that you're able to search for images
using text for example here pizza on the
left or you can recognize what people
are in the photos and you can search by
those i love how the website design is
like exactly like google photos but the
icon in the browser is just like the
default react icon in any case very cool
open source check it out orliable is a
library by google research that is
supposed to make evaluation of
reinforcement learning agents more
reproducible so this does things like
score normalization stratified
bootstrapping and calculates various
other metrics that make reinforcement
learning algorithms just a bit more
comparable than like a single number on
the atari benchmark very cool code is on
github check it out met mnist v2 is a
data set that seeks to be an mnist-like
collection of standardized biomedical
images so these are various data sets 18
to be exact 12 of them are in 2d 8 28 by
28 pixels and 6 of them are in 3d 28 by
28 by 28 voxels they say everything is
available in standard formats with
corresponding classification labels no
background knowledge is required for
users so if you're looking for an easy
entry into biomedical data this might be
for you i especially love the papers
with code usage graph right here the
histogram
number of papers
one
excellent
and lastly we have an article from
fortune saying ai won't break your
company's culture and it might even
boost morale this goes along with a new
report by people associated with the
boston consulting group as far as i can
tell about the cultural benefits of
artificial intelligence in the
enterprise so the article is trying to
make the point that introducing ai
products or ai mechanisms into companies
might lead to various benefits
especially benefits that people might
not realize initially but it just sounds
like this has been written by an ai to
sort of make humans comply more saying
things like every ceo worries that
culture will make or break their
company's ai deployment but few realize
that conversely ai can also transform
organizational culture specifically
using ai results in the following
more collective learning greater
collaboration clearer roles higher
morale saying things like as many as 79
of the survey respondents reported an
increase in morale after deployment of
ai in their companies like what
this is definitely written by an ai to
make us more compliant look at all these
benefits if you use a.i ceo but you know
if the carrot isn't working you also
need to get out the stick which the ai
authors of this article definitely
understand so in the last paragraph
saying deploying ai at scale may not be
easy but ceos would do well to remember
that doing so will not only deliver
financial benefits but also create high
performance cultures ceos would do well
to remember
excellent stuff right here totally
humans who wrote this totally thank you
alright this was already it for this
week's ml news thank you so much for
being here listening let me know what
you think in the comments stay tuned for
next week bye bye
[Music]
you